nice I'll try to remember the rating
graphic for this video unlike my Aquaman
review go figure the one review ever
that I forget the writing graphic it's
the first video in months that ends up
on the trending page of YouTube oh maybe
I should forget the graphic more often
we'll see
[Music]
MARY POPPINS return so Mary Poppins
returns is the sequel to the beloved
classic Mary Poppins and Mary Poppins
returns Mary Poppins everyone's favorite
narcissistic pathological lying nanny
does return the one you know is true she
denies any magic ever happening when it
happens and she self proclaims and she's
practically perfect in every way we do
love her
we love our narcissist add some B&E into
this - she busts into someone's house
kicks the door in anyhow Emily Blunt
plays Mary Poppins now the banks
children from the original Mary Poppins
they're grown about as grown up as they
would be it's not in real time it's like
20 years later or so maybe 30 25 we'll
split the difference I don't know for
sure I know somebody has said hey it's
this many years after the original Mary
Poppins I'm gonna say a solid 25 or 30
27 Michael Banks has fallen on hard
times he might lose the house family
stressed out enter Mary Poppins she will
save the day and really this is an
enjoyable movie it's an enjoyable family
movie it's a Mary Poppins for a new
generation but the phrase perplexes me
now it might have been a timer I was
like yeah this for a new generation I
get it but now I'm looking back I'm like
Mary Poppins for a new generation is
Mary Poppins for the old generations the
movie exists this generation has access
to it like the old generation did so it
totally works especially since really
this movie follows a lot of the same
beats as the original like it's 2015 all
over again
now Emily Blunt is great as Mary Poppins
this isn't like Mary Poppins as a kid or
anything like that this is the same
character and there is not a person
living and breathing today who could do
a better Mary Poppins than Emily Blunt
Emily Blunt played a better Mary Poppins
for a modern movie Harrison Ford played
in Indiana Jones for a modern moment to
the point she was really good and the
big bummer is the Mary Poppins music
from the original its iconic maybe it's
just me but I know those twos and those
tunes are very catchy I don't feel like
there will ever be a realm of existence
where I remember the music in this movie
they're a couple of catchy tunes sure
but there's nothing let's go fly okay
nothing like that there is a pretty fun
dance sequence sure it's with the Bert
character but in this movie who's not
really Bert but he's totally Bert he's a
grown-up who when he was a kid Mary
Poppins was his nanny and he remembers
so he's along for the ride as a side
character totally Bert but not burned
but he's just not as memorable to me as
Bert I mean said what you want about
dick Van Dyke's accent Bob Dick Van Dyke
had an animated quality about him I
still remember him like dragging his
stick on the ground on parole
lin-manuel miranda who plays that
character in this movie though he has
good dance sequences in this movie he's
not going to stand out like Bert
he lights light torches on the street so
of course he and a bunch of light torch
guys do dances around light torches it's
not as good as that I'm never gonna hum
the song that they played there who
knows maybe this new generation will and
if you do great or or you just popping
the original Mary Poppins and see if
they'll hum that there were some neat
sequences in this movie too like the
animated one I thought it was really
cool familiar yeah but entertaining
that's what this movie is like
everything can be summed up with that
phrase familiar yeah but entertaining
but because this movie follows such the
same piece about I feel like I would
argue Mary Poppins Returns follows Mary
Poppins beats more than the force
awakens follows the original Star Wars
beats I don't know I said it but I mean
it's all under the Disney umbrella
though so I'm sure that was the argument
like that was the inspiration if they
ever make a movie about this movie being
made instead of saving mr. banks it'll
be called milking mr. banks in which
case it'll be one dude in a room full of
people going
all right folks Mary Poppins you know
the name you know the film it's a crown
jewel of the studio we're gonna make a
sequel but it's gonna follow the same
peach is the original movie work for
Star Wars so we're gonna do it now give
me a script by the end of the day you
want a draft kid
there's your draft right there you're
welcome let's go to lunch
enemy that's it this movie does have a
couple of heartfelt moments there's one
scene where Michael banks is just he's
kind of at his wits end and he's just
really stressed out that was the moment
I personally feel that's the best moment
in the movie it's not posturing it
doesn't have any of the grandiose the
flare it has magic but not visual manner
this is a very personal moment I really
liked guys in the end Mary Poppins
returns it was a safe sequel Emily Blunt
was great as Mary Poppins in fact most
of the cast was really good the movie
was enjoyably safe or safely enjoyable
but by the end he gave me the family
feels sounded weird don't make it weird
give me the feelings made me feel good
and that is succeeded in what it was
doing I just wish the music was more
memorable but I'll say Mary Poppins
Returns was a fine time no alcohol
required dad matinee price sometimes a
shoehorn that in because I just can't
say full price at night another thing is
that alcohol kind of movie but anything
there is this scene where people are
floating on balloons and I was like at
what point did the balloon stop did the
balloons notice doc does Mary Poppins
stop them or is it like oh thank you for
the balloon Mary Poppins I'm flirting
away good boy
hello hey is anyone there it's really
cold up here how high does this go MARY
POPPINS words for each allergy I just
wondered that about some of her tricks
sometimes like she always denying it
unless are some Mary Poppins returns
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]